d'elancourt aux mureaux en passant par
plaisir et maurs la jolie les projets
artistiques porté par des femmes ont
fait le tour des yvelines promouvoir
l'égalité hommes-femmes dans la culture
en festival menées depuis fin février
par l'association créative le bilan est
encore provisoire on est déjà treize
mille spectateurs sur l'ensemble de
l'opération
on a eu donc c'est 60 de représentation
on a eu plus de 140 femmes qui ont été
présentes sur ce sur cette opération là
et donc ça c'est plutôt oui une réussite
parce que on sait qu'on a rencontré
réellement et un public des partenaires
et en même temps une cause
au total quatorze structures ont
accueilli les différentes
représentations pendant quarante et un
jours la clôture a eu lieu le 31 mars
avec la pièce les maîtres du monde
il ya effectivement quelques rares
personnes qui s'intéressent à défendre
mais voilà les les projets portés par
des femmes et je pense que si ces gens
là existent c'est parce que ils doivent
eux-mêmes ressentir la nécessité d'un
manque de relais à cet endroit là et moi
j'aimerais pouvoir être programmé
autrement dans ce cadre évidemment en
tant qu'artiste tout simplement au delà
de mon sexe et de mon genre aujourd'hui
encore le secteur ne compte que 12 % de
directrice de théâtres nationaux
avec ce festival le réseau créative
espère avoir sensibilisé le public au
delà des yvelines